hello there guys and welcome to another
video in this video we're covering
another leak for spider-man no way home
so it seems the official poster has been
leaked on public transport in melbourne
australia so it reads here reddit user
pap banana bread gabe posted what
appears to be an official poster for
marvel studios and sony pictures
spider-man no way home the poster was
spotted by multiple people in a public
transport in melbourne australia and a
one shared and reddit appeared on the
side of a local bus tom holland
spider-man is seen posing in his iron
spider armor with an upside down
multiverse twisted new york above him as
he takes on the tentacles of doctor
octopus and on the screen here you can
see an enhanced rendering of the poster
now to me this looks pretty official and
there's actually numerous reports of
this poster being seen on public
transport so that makes me to believe
that this is actually true and this is a
real poster um but my one question is
why have they taken so long to release
this poster because you know why
wouldn't they just release this with the
first official trailer because in this
poster they don't show any other
spider-man they don't show anything that
we haven't seen from the first trailer
so if they're worried about spoiling
things and that's why they've been
waiting to share this poster possibly
you don't want to spoil the appearance
of spider-man or so forth then that
makes sense but this poster here it
shows everything we've seen in the first
trailer so you know why not just release
it with the first trailer i'm not sure i
don't have an answer for that but um
supposedly there is a rumor that this
poster or another poster will be
released soon so i guess we'll just have
to wait and see um but with rumors
remember to just take it with a grain of
salt anyway guys with that out of the
way tell me what do you think of this
poster and are you excited for spiderman
no way home let me know in the comment
section below and i'll catch you guys in
the next video
[Music]